bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
de ce que certains considèrent comme le
problème le plus important et le plus
difficile des mathématiques
l'hypothèse de riemann cette hypothèse a
été formulée en 1859 par le
mathématicien allemand bernhard riemann
et jusqu'ici personne n'a réussi à le
démontrer même si la plupart des
chercheurs pensent qu'elle est très
certainement vrai vous avez peut-être
qu'en mathématiques il existe un certain
nombre de situations de ce type des
conjectures que tous les mathématiciens
considère comme vrai mais que personne
n'arrive à démontrer alors pourquoi
l'hypothèse de riemann est elle si
particulière a déjà d'un point de vue
bassement matérielles
il faut savoir qu elle fait partie des
sept problèmes du millénaire pour
lesquels l'institut clay offre un prix
d'un million de dollars à qui on
trouvera une solution
mais ça les vrais mathématicien s'en
fiche ce qui les fascine avant tout
c'est que l'hypothèse de riemann propose
une connexion entre deux chants des
mathématiques qui à première vue n'ont
pas grand chose à voir
d'un côté les nombres premiers et de
l'autre côté un domaine qu'on appelle
l'analyse complexe et pour bien
comprendre ce lien qu'établit
l'hypothèse de riemann on va commencer
par parler du plus simple de ces deux
domaines les nombres premiers
[Musique]
commençons par rappeler ce qu'est un
nombre premier il s'agit d'un nombre
entier qu'on ne peut pas diviser à part
par un et par lui même évidemment par
convention on exclut le 1 et donc les
nombreux promeneurs
on en connaît plein 2 3 5 7 11 13 et
c'est depuis très longtemps les
mathématiciens se pose plein de
questions sur les nombres premiers
quelle quantité y en a comme henry se
répartissent ou est-ce qu'on en trouve
certaines de ces questions sont résolus
depuis bien longtemps par exemple il ya
plus de 2000 ans euclide avait déjà
démontré qu'il existe une infinité de
nombreux premiers on sait aussi que les
nombres premiers se raréfient on en
trouve de moins en moins souvent à
mesure qu'ils augmentent par exemple
entre 0 et 100 on en trouve 25 donc un
quart des nombres sont premiers dans cet
intervalle mais entre 1000 et 1100 mais
y'en a plus que 16 et entre 1 million et
un million cent on en trouve seulement 6
pour comprendre la manière dont se
distribuent les nombres premiers et pour
représenter où on en trouve
on peut définir une fonction très simple
qu'on appelle la fonction de répartition
c'est une fonction qui compte simplement
la quantité de nombreux premiers entre 0
et x6 on cherche tous les nombres
premiers par exemple entre 0 et 200 et
comptera cette fonction eh bien on voit
qu'elle a évidemment une forme en
escalier un à chaque nombres premiers
elles augmentent de 1
ici on peut lire la valeur que je
mentionnais tout à l'heure il ya 25
nombres premiers entre 0 et 100 et de
façon générale puisque les nombres
premiers se raréfient on va avoir des
plateaux de plus en plus longs avec des
marches d'escalier de moins en moins
souvent pour tracer cette fonction de
répartition on a malheureusement pas de
formules toutes faites
on est obligé de chercher tous les
nombres premiers dans un certaine
intervalles puis à partir de la liste de
tracer la fonction et chercher tous les
nombres premiers dans un intervalle
c'est assez fastidieux parce qu'on est
forcé d'une façon ou d'une autre de
traiter tous les nombres afin d'éliminer
ceux qui ne sont pas premiers cette
fonction de répartition on ne sait donc
pas la trace et sans avoir préalablement
la liste des nombres premiers
mais on en connaît quelques
approximations la première c'est la
fonction x / logarithme de x c'est une
fonction très simple dont la forme
générale suit celle de la fonction de
répartition et qui permet comme ça de
connaître en gros la quantité de nombres
premier dans un intervalle donné même si
vous le voyez elle est toujours un peu
en dessous de la réalité
mais il existe une autre approximations
un peu meilleur que ça c'est une
fonction qu'on appelle le logarithme
intégral noter l i 2 x ici elle est
tracée entre 0 et 1000 et vous voyez que
c'est pas trop mal hein on est un peu au
dessus de la fonction de répartition
cette fois mes tracés entre 0 et 100
mille vous voyez que ça colle assez bien
mieux que la fonction précédente alors
une des choses café trimane c'est
d'abord de proposer une approximation
encore meilleure que celle ci qui est
une variante 1 fabriqué à partir de la
fonction elie ii x etc on note parfois r
i 2 x en hommage à rimane justement si
je trace cette fonction et reader x vous
voyez que là c'est vraiment une très
bonne approximation la fonction de
répartition elle passe vraiment bien au
milieu
parfois elle est légèrement au dessus
parfois légèrement en dessous mais dans
l'ensemble c'est vraiment pas mal du
tout le problème de cette approximation
c'est qu'elle suit la tendance générale
mais là pas du tout cette structure en
escalier qu'à la fonction de répartition
et par conséquent elle ne nous dit rien
des endroits où se produisent les petits
sous et où se trouvent précisément les
nombres premiers
on peut donc pas utiliser cette
approximation pour deviner à l'avancé où
vont se trouver les nombres premiers
un truc qui fait rêver les
mathématiciens se serait de posséder une
expression une formule d'une fonction de
ce genre qui aurait la structure en
escalier de façon à pouvoir prédire
précisément la localisation des nombres
premiers
l'idéal ce serait d'avoir la formule
d'une fonction qui fasse un peu comme ça
et bien c'est ça qu'a réussi à faire
rimal enfin presque
et pour vous faire comprendre comment on
va devoir faire un détour par quelque
chose qui n'a en apparence rien à voir
les sommes ainsi nous
[Musique]
en mathématiques on peut faire des
additions on peut additionner deux
nombres trois nombres 29 nombre autant
que vous voulez en fait mais en plus de
ça il existe des circonstances
particulières dans lesquelles on peut
faire la somme d'une infinité de nombres
prenons un exemple simple considérer la
somme 1/2 plus un car plus un 8e +1 16e
puis 1 32e puis 1 64e
et c'est jusqu'à l'infini c'est une
somme qu'on peut calculer
progressivement et si vous le faites
vous allez vous rendre compte qu'on se
rapproche de plus en plus de 1
ça serait très bien si on en fait une
représentation comme des parts de gâteau
on a une somme avec une infinité de
terme mais dont le résultat est un
nombre fini on dit qu'elle converge ces
sommes infinie les mathématiciens
appelle ça des séries alors oui
attention si un matin où une matheuse
vous propose de venir chez lui regarder
des séries
méfiez-vous ça va pas être exactement
netflix en chine bref une somme infinie
c'est une série et parfois mais pas
toujours la série convergent vers une
valeur fini les séries on peut en
fabriquer plein par exemple un plus un
car plus un ne viennent plus un 16e 25e
etc
vous remarquez le motif au dénominateur
on met le carré des nombres entiers et
cette série convergent vers 1,6400 49 et
des brouettes
on peut aussi faire la même avec des
cubes au lieu des carrés des nombres
entiers un plus un sur deux en cubes + 1
sur 3 occupe plus un sur quatre au cube
et c est la série convergent aussi vers
1,202 et quelques et ce principe on peut
essayer de le généraliser avec n'importe
quelle puissance même des puissances de
nombre qui ne sont pas des entier disons
6,3 et bien on peut écrire un plus un
sur deux puissances 6,3 plus un sur
trois puissantes 6 3 puis 1 sur 4
puissant 6-3 et ses voiliers peut-être
où je veux en venir ce petit jeu on peut
le faire avec n'importe quel nombre x et
donc de façon générale on peut
considérer la fonction suivantes 1 + 1
sur 2 puissance x + 1 sur 3 puissance x
+ 1 sur 4 puissance x etc et on peut
montrer que dès que x est strictement
plus grand que rhin et bien la série
convergent et la fonction a un sens or
normalement à ce stade vous vous
demandez pourquoi j'ai introduit la
fonction f 2 x à la définition si
alambiquées et quels rapports ça peut
avoir avec les nombres premiers
et bien la raison c'est une drôle de
relation découverte avant riman
le mathématicien suisse leonhard euler
cette fonction f 2 x est exactement égal
à cette expression qui est cette fois un
produit infinie et si vous la regardez
de près vous remarqué que dans ce
produit un fini on ne trouve pas un
terme pour chaque nombre entier mais
seulement chaque nombreux premiers la
formule de l'air que vous sembler
étrange avec cette histoire de produits
infinie mais elle nous montre qu'il
existe une connexion profonde avec les
nombres premiers
et ce lien bernhard riemann l'a poussé
beaucoup plus loin je voulais dit la
fonction f 2 x n'est défini que pour des
nombreux x strictement plus grand que ce
café rimane c'est de montrer qu'on peut
prolonger la définition de cette
fonction de façon beaucoup plus large
notamment pour les nombreux complexes
alors petite parenthèse les nombres
complexes ce sont ceux qu'on peut écrire
sous la forme z égale x plus y x y ou y
et le nombre imaginaire tels que icare
est égale moins-11 nombres complexes z
il faut donc deux nombres réels x et y
pour le décrire le moyen le plus simple
de visualiser les nombres complexes
c'est de se dire qu'il se représente
comme des points du plan de coordonnées
x et y
on appelle l'ensemble le plan complexe
là où les nombres réels ne sont qu'une
droite et comme je les dis ce qu'a
trouvé rimane c'est un moyen de
prolonger la définition de la fonction
depuis cette portion de droite jusqu'à
l'ensemble du plan des nombres complexes
cette opération de prolongement est là
rien d'évident et je vais pas rentrer
dans les détails
pour les curieux il y à une vidéo de l j
j et une autre de tribhuwan wang qui
l'expliquent trade à ce qu'il faut
retenir c'est que ce prolongement est en
quelque sorte unique et donc riman à
trouver la seule façon de définir cette
fonction sur tous les nombres complexes
cette fonction prolongée on l'appelle la
fonction des états bah oui parce que les
lettres grecques ça fait quand même plus
chic
voilà vous connaissez maintenant la
fameuse fonction des états de rimal et
grâce à la relation qu avait découvert
en l'air avant lui
vous comprenez qu'elle a certainement un
vague lien avec les nombres premiers
bien alors revenons maintenant à notre
problème d'origine la répartition de ces
nombres premiers
je voulais déjà dit la fonction est
réintroduite par imane est une très
bonne approximation de la fonction de
répartition mais elle n'a pas du tout le
comportement en marche d'escalier et ce
qu'a découvert riman c'est une fonction
qui à cette forme et qui est une
pleu modification de la fonction eric
pour ça on part de la fonction et rit et
on va lui apporter des petites
déformations des corrections
ce qui est génial c'est que ces
corrections s'exprime aussi à partir de
la fonction et rient mais en l'évaluant
au point x puissance z pour tous les
points complexes z ou la fonction des
états ça nul alors expliquons ça
tranquillement pour être bien clair on
peut imaginer que la fonction des zetas
annuler en un certain nombre de points
du plan complexe
ces points là on les appelle les héros
de la fonction des états en supposant
qu'on les connaisse et appelons les
aides quinzaine 2 3 etc pour faire les
corrections dont je parlais vous partez
de la fonction et reader x et vous lui
retirez herry 2x puissance z pour chacun
des 0 on fait donc herry 2 x - et riz 2
x puissance zelda - herry 2x puissance
des deux - et reader x puissance des 2 3
etc
chaque 0 de la fonction et a fourni une
petite correction ce qu'a démontré
rimane c'est que si on connaît tous les
héros de la fonction des états alors en
faisant toutes les corrections
on tombe exactement sur la fonction de
répartition des nombres premiers
avec sa structure en escalier ah ok très
bien mais maintenant il va falloir les
trouver ces 0 et je vous rappelle qu'on
doit aller chercher parmi les nombreux
complexes un don dans le plan complexe
alors pour ça sur ce dessin j'ai
représenté en niveaux de gris ce qu'on
appelle le module de la fonction des
états plus cette valeur est faible plus
le gris est clair et les héros
correspondent donc aux points blancs de
cette image on peut observer deux choses
tout d'abord on a des héros en moins 2 -
4 - 6 - 8
et c'est en fait pour tous les nombres
pairs négatif la fonction des états
s'annulent on celle démontrée et c'est
ce que les mathématiciens appelle les
héros triviaux de la fonction mais vous
voyez qu'on ad'autres 0 ici et il semble
tous alignés sur cette droite verticale
qui est celle qui correspond au nombre
complexe de partir et elle induit on
appelle cette droite la droite critique
si on trace spécifiquement la fonction
des étals long de cette droite
critiquent en oubliant tout le reste du
plan voici ce qu'on observe vous voyez
qu'on trouve plein de zéros or c'est
bien mais d'une part ils n'ont rien de
remarquable ce ne sont pas des nombres
entiers ou demi entier ou autre chose de
ce genre arrive blair un peu aléatoire
et en plus on ne distingue pas de
régularité particulière dans l'eure
partition parfois on a beaucoup
d'espèces entre deux parfois ils
s'enchaînent presque immédiatement est
la question que s'est posée rimane c'est
à part - 2 - 4 - 6 et c est ce que tous
les héros de la fonction des états sont
sur cette droite critiquent ou bien
est-ce qu'il en existerait d'autres
ailleurs et c'est important puisque la
connaissance de ces 0 permet de faire
toutes les corrections dont on a besoin
pour retrouver la fonction de
répartition des nombres premiers
et bien c'est ça qu'on appelle
l'hypothèse de riemann l'affirmation
selon laquelle tous les héros non
triviaux se trouve sur la droite
critique alors on a de très bonnes
raisons de penser que c'est vrai puisque
pour l'instant on a trouvé plus de dix
mille milliards sur cette droite et
jamais aucun en dehors vous savez quand
matin ça ne garantit pas que ce soit
vrai tout le temps pour vous illustrer
l'intérêt de cette hypothèse regardez ce
qu'elle permet de faire ici j'ai la
fonction de répartition des nombres
premiers en bleu avec sa structure en
escalier et la fonction et riz en rouge
et maintenant je vais au fur et à mesure
ajoutez des corrections en prenant
successivement les héros qu'on trouve
sur la droite critiquent et bien vous
voyez que ça ajoute des petites
corrections en oscillations qui quand on
en a rajouté suffisamment finissent par
très bien suivre les escaliers de la
fonction de répartition et nous disent
donc exactement où trouver les nombres
premiers
on a même l'impression qu'au bout d'un
moment on n'a même plus besoin d'ajouter
des corrections supplémentaires alors
malheureusement plus on veut aller loin
dans le tracé de la courbe plus il va
falloir ajouter de correction est donc
plus il sera important d'être certain
qu'on n'a pas loupé des zéros de la
fonction des états si l'hypothèse de
riemann est vrai on peut se contenter de
les chercher sur la droite critiquent
mais dans le cas contraire et bien on
est cuit on risque d'en louper
en résumé la fonction d'état contient
donc en elle la clé de la répartition
des nombres premiers
alors en pratique utiliser les héros de
la fonction des états n'est peut-être
pas le moyen le plus simple de trouver
des nombres premiers
mais l'intérêt théorique de l'hypothèse
de riemann réside surtout dans le pont
qu'elle établit entre ces deux domaines
si éloignées l'arithmétique et l'analyse
complexe
aujourd'hui on l'a dit la plupart des
mathématiciens considère que l'hypothèse
de riemann est vrai et qui doit être
possible d'en trouver une démonstration
mais ça semble pour le moins value comme
problème d'ailleurs il ya un siècle le
mathématicien david hilbert tu disais
déjà que s'il se réveillait d'un sommeil
de milan la première question qu'ils
poseraient serait est-ce que l'hypothèse
de riemann a été démontrée alors
évidemment certains mathématicien essaye
de la trouver cette démonstration mais
d'autres font ce qu on fait parfois en
mathématiques ils partent du principe
que l'hypothèse est vrai et regarde ce
qu'on peut démontrer avec je vous donne
un exemple un peu fou vous vous souvenez
de mes fonctions d'approximations au
début il y avait la fonction x /
logarithme 2x qui semble toujours en
dessous de la fonction de répartition et
puis la fonction et lydie x qui elle
semblait plus proche mais toujours au
dessus
eh bien on sait depuis environ un siècle
que non elle n'est pas toujours au
dessus il ya un moment où elle passe en
dessous puis après elle revient au
dessus et repasse en dessous et c est en
fait on peut démontrer que les deux
courbes se croisent une infinité de fois
le problème c'est qu'on n'a jamais pu
l'observer
on a regardé jusqu'à des milliards de
milliards pas de croisement
on peut donc légitimement se demander à
partir de quel moment va se produire le
premier croisement
le mathématicien style escuse a pu
démontrer qu'il devait forcément se
produire avant 10 puissance 10 puissance
10 puissance 964 alors sachant qu'il ya
10 puissance 80 atom dans l'univers
visible c'est un nombre qu'on pourrait
même pas écrire si on voulait le mais
bon et bien en supposant que l'hypothèse
de riemann soit vrai
ce que ça a pu améliorer le résultat en
montrant que la version devait se
produire en fait avant 10 puissance 10
puissance 10 puissance 34,1 nombre
incroyablement plus petit que le
précédent mais qu'on peut toujours pas
écrit non plus et mieux en faisant des
approximations avec les héros de la
fonction des états qu'on connaît et en
supposant qui en a par ailleurs on a pu
resserrer le résultat et on pense
maintenant que la première version
devrait se produire autour de 10
puissance 316 ça fait loin quand même
une chose que j'ai mentionné au début de
la vidéo et qui n'a peut-être pas
échappé à certains c'est que l'hypothèse
de riemann fait partie des sept
problèmes du millénaire à un million de
dollars
mais bon vu le calibre de l'énigme on
peut considérer que tenter de démontrer
l'hypothèse de riemann est probablement
la manière la plus inefficace et la plus
incertaine qui soit d'essayer de gagner
un million de
à moins que à moins qu'elle soit fausse
mais dans ce cas c'est simple trouver un
point d'annulation un seul qui ne soit
pas sur la droite critiquent et vous
aideront à vous le magot alors une piste
si c'est ça votre stratégie
on s'est montré que les héros non
triviaux ne peuvent exister que dans la
bande entre 0 et 1 2 parties réelles
c'est ce qu'on appelle la bande critique
et en plus de ça l'immense majorité des
héros se trouve tout près de la drogue
critique donc voilà vous savez où
chercher si vous voulez trouver un
contre-exemple à l'hypothèse de riemann
mais je sais pas je parierais pas trop
dessus quand même alors sachez tout de
même que fin 2018 le mathématicien
michel attiyah a proposé une
démonstration de l'hypothèse de riemann
qui malheureusement ne semble pas du
tout convaincre la communauté et pour en
savoir plus je vous renvoie à cette
vidéo de professeurs culture précieuse
voilà c'est tout pour aujourd'hui merci
d'avoir suivi la vidéo comme toujours le
blog pour les compléments facebook et
twitter pour la q2 la chaîne
abonnez-vous la cloche tout ça et on se
retrouve très vite pour une nouvelle
vidéo
à bientôt
[Musique]